I've been using the airpods Pro 2 for
two weeks now and in this review I'm
going to cover everything I found both
the good and some bad also share how
they compare to my airpods Max which
I've used for a long time and loved and
cover some really shady business from
Apple I'm not gonna cover all the specs
and details but I want to talk about
real world usage and with that I'm going
to start out with sound quality I
usually leave that to the end but man
this is amazing some people have said
that if you want to upgrade just for
sound quality don't do it but I
completely disagree starting off with
the Sound Stage I have never heard any
pair of wireless earbuds sound so good
apple developed brand new drivers for
these so that is part of the reason but
the other part is because they changed
the venting system and that helped
increase the sound stage so you hear
stuff a lot wider doesn't sound like the
sound is just in your ears but a
downside to that is that this sound
leakage is quite a bit worse not as bad
as the airpods 3 that don't seal in at
all but previously people could barely
hear music and now if you turn it up
they will instrument separation has also
been improved in some heavy tracks where
you have a lot of different sounds you
can pick up different instruments much
better than before vocals also stand out
more so so that has been really nice but
what has impressed me by far the most is
the bass I couldn't believe how loudly
these played at 20 Hertz most lower end
sound systems for theaters don't even
hit that low or they're super quiet
where these ones were actually louder
than the airpods max now that made no
sense to me because these are over ears
and so I played a 20 Hertz test track
and then I opened up the app that shows
you how loud it's playing and the
airpods Pro 2 played at 68 decibels
compared to 50 86 for the airpods max
now when you're playing that low a lot
of it is based that you feel instead of
here and even though the airpods max you
feel it all around your ears because
they're over ears these just thumped my
eardrums that made me curious about how
low can these play so I played 15 Hertz
and even though it got a lot quieter
than 20 Hertz it still was able to play
it I could feel it in my ears and most
music tracks actually don't play this
low so you have to find specialized ones
that are tuned for people that have
subwoofers and their cars and it is
really cool to have that now for those
of you guys that don't like music that
have a ton of bass when you're watching
movies and you have these in the
experience is fantastic with that these
also play louder than the airpods max
hitting 101 decibels compared to 99 now
that is not great for your eardrum so if
you like loud music or you're watching
movies it is nice to have so overall
it's a huge Improvement in every single
way compared to the original airpods Pro
and even though I would say the airpods
max do sound better overall I just think
that these sounds so good that most
people don't need these anymore we'll
also talk about noise canceling in a bit
now what shocked me even more is the
updated spatialized audio now I was a
huge fan of spatialized audio when it
came out and it was limited to head
tracking when they added the fixed mode
it got better and in some cases it did
sound good and proves The Sound Stage
but in many it was a little bit too
digital but with these and the new
personalized spatialized audio where it
will literally use the lidar and scan
your ears and the front of your face and
adjust that it is shockingly good I
can't believe that I'm saying this but I
actually use spatialize audio now more
often than not compared to before where
I only use it about five percent of the
time the Sound Stage is crazy you hear
instruments spread out around you the
vocals are popping forward and at one
point when I was using him I thought
that something fell in the other room
because of a sound in a song that
sounded so different that I literally
thought something was happening far away
it is incredible now most reviewers have
said that the transparency mode it
sounds wonderful like it always has but
I've noticed some bigger differences I
think the biggest one is the accuracy of
the placement of transparent sound for
example you're walking outside instead
of hearing sounds and it sounds like
it's right there next to you you can
actually pinpoint that a car could be
driving from behind you on their right
hand side or on the left hand side that
is a major Improvement especially for
safety and the new adaptive transparency
mode has also been nice to have now I
tested this out and I was using my leaf
blower and I thought that it wasn't
really making much of a difference
holding it at arm's length and then when
I picked it up and brought it closer it
didn't get any louder because it was
limiting that sound and while I wouldn't
suggest this to be hearing protection
for you it is nice to have those super
loud annoying sounds brought down now as
far as usability the microphones have
also been improved with the originals I
would always ask people how do you hear
me and sometimes I'd have to switch over
to my phone I have not had a single
person complain about how I sounded
whether connected to my Mac or my iPhone
now as far as microphone quality the
original airpods which I'm using right
now they were never amazing they're okay
and lately they have also been
superseded and this is the microphone
quality of the airpods pro 2. now you
guys let me know in the comments if they
sound any better I've also started to
use the new sliding gesture on the
earbud to be able to adjust the volume I
had to force myself to do that to learn
and remember it and it has come in handy
I just wish they gave us a control to be
able to adjust how sensitive that is
because right now it barely makes a
difference each time you slide the
battery life has been great I've never
had them die on me Apple quote 6 hours
hours I think it's right there and while
most people will say I didn't really
care about that keep in mind that after
a couple years the tiny batteries wear
out and your original four four and a
half hour battery life will be down to
two and then it really sucks I highly
recommend AppleCare because of that and
being a person that really pays for
AppleCare I do with my earpods because
if the battery capacity goes lower than
80 within two years Apple will replace
them and that is a bargain for the low
price that they offer and now let's talk
about noise canceling because it is
shockingly good now I previously
mentioned that when I was testing them
out in the pouring rain the higher
frequency of the Raindrops Were quieter
than on the airpods max now I haven't
been able to fly with these yet but I
have an even tougher situation you guys
know what it is it is my lawnmower that
runs at 89 to 90 decibels and that can
harm your hearing in as low as 15
minutes and the airpods Pro 2 brought
that down from 89 decibels to 62.
previously I would take home the airpods
max when I was mowing and I didn't
expect the airpods Pro 2 to do better
how could they they're so small they're
not over the ear and I couldn't believe
it when they did a better job how in the
world is that even possible I also
noticed it in my truck when I start up
and that V8 is super loud before it
warms up the airpods Pro 2 did better
than the airpods max now I honestly
thought this has to be a placebo effect
right you spend money in the device you
want to think that it is better so I
started doing some digging online what I
found was quite Shady a lot of people
talking about how the airpods max got
worse with a firmware update that came
out the same day that the airpods Pro 2
came out one guy had to use his airpods
Maxes for many flights and now with the
update the active noise cancellation is
a lot worse the plane is noticeably
louder and the new airpods Pro 2 that he
got were a lot quieter another person
usually didn't hear his Roomba Vacuum
but now it is noticeable and Audible and
even though he doesn't have the airpod
pros too his original Pros have also
gotten noticeably worse from the update
that was also Auto installed the day the
new ones launched I think this is quite
Shady even though these perform great it
is really weird to see that other
products that were good before got worse
now I don't know if that's just to prop
up these new ones or there's new airpods
Max coming out or what is going on but
that should not be happening so now I'm
thinking why do I even need the airpods
max they do sound better overall but
these still sound so fantastic these are
less convenient the active noise
cancellation Works worse while these
airpod Pros 2 are less than half the
price honestly I don't know when I'm
gonna use the airpods max maybe when I
need to have it wired to a computer but
with that delay latency on these new
airpods Pros too are better they switch
super fast from device to device if they
don't auto switch you click it it's done
the previous air pods like my threes
those took quite a bit longer and to
have Precision tracking to be able to
find them when you lose them I only had
that happen one time when they fell into
my couch it is so stress relieving to be
guided to the right spot to be able to
have the little light go off the speaker
in the case to start playing it is just
so nice that that little extra will save
you from losing them having to buy
another pair overall I think these are
the ultimate earbuds they're not the
best in every category but for the price
they are great and if somebody is
questioning if they should upgrade it is
an absolute yes for every single
category so I highly recommend them and
I think this might be my favorite
product that Apple launched this
September you guys let me know your
thoughts we have links down below click
above to subscribe if you guys want to
see more videos check out those videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]